The red light therapy stimulates cancer growth. I wanted to try it on solar muscles.
No, I don't think so. There's a lot of, you know, a lot of promises made with the sale of
different products. The red light therapy is one that's probably there's a lot of, I don't know how
to say it nicely. There's a lot of overselling. There's a lot of lies told when selling different
products, sometimes that are just not right. And I know we get questions, why don't you sell,
you know, these different red light therapy things? It's because I just don't believe in them.
That they make the changes that they say they make. And you could easily say, hey, you should
look at this study. Well, this study on this light therapy was done at a much stronger device than
the ones that they're selling for 150 bucks. So I just don't see. And maybe there's a lot of
testimonials where maybe you'll try it and it'll work really good. So I hate to knock something
that might work. But I just, it's like the, it's like the people will say I'm using an infrared
light, because then they'll pull up these studies on how infrared is so good for, you know,
increase in circulation and killing, you know, causing deep heat and actually killing cancer cells
and things. But then the device itself is not really infrared. There may be one tenth of one percent
infrared coming out of the device. So they legally can sell it as an infrared device. But it's not
truly an infrared device. Most of those that you can buy like that actually show their colored light.
Well, infrared is not going to show any light because it's the need to the spectrum. So
you just gotta be careful with stuff like that. I guess I'm not talking to somebody of this might
be listening to someone say, I use an infrared light. Oh my gosh, it helps me so much. Well,
I keep using it. But I just more skeptical on some of these things. So